what's going on guys this is rob and
it's been a little while since we
covered thor right now what's going on
is actually a story all called the war
of hammers and yes it is every bit as
awesome as you think it is it is an
amazing story
right now we're covering the story arc
of revelations right that's the one that
happened immediately after the story arc
of donald blake so as we've been doing
recently or not even recently for a
little while now we'll have a link to
the thor playlist down in the
description this video will be at the
very end of the playlist always remember
when it comes to the playlist that we do
we start with the oldest videos and run
to the newest videos right so go into
the playlist scroll all the way to the
bottom and you'll see this video there
having said that this basically picks up
with the ongoing struggle of thor right
one of the things to keep in mind thor's
been basically dealing with this idea
that for whatever reason he cannot lift
his hammer but everybody else can now if
we're being honest with ourselves this
is kind of donnie kate's sort of poking
fun at what's been happening in the thor
comics in recent years right you guys
probably noticed this now in recent
years there's been this circumstance
where like for whatever reason thor
can't lift his hammer but somebody else
can't and honestly that's one of those
things that happened ever since the days
of beta ray bill vader ray bill was
introduced during the legendary walt
simonsen run he was the first person to
lift thor's hammer everybody was like oh
my god that's crazy and then it's just
something marvel's done over over time
just for like shock value right like
captain america gets the hammer jane
foster gets the hammer steve the guy
that bagged my groceries at the grocery
store yesterday gets the hammer
right everybody gets the hammer of thor
and in all honesty it's like one of the
big complaints the fans have but i love
the way that donnie kate is handling
this because it's kind of like this
ongoing mystery right and even thor to a
degree kind of answers it in this story
but one of the things that happens
coming off the heels of the whole donald
blake thing is you've basically got what
always happens in asgard right after
just some great big huge crazy event or
fight or something like that right
everybody's drinking everybody's
partying it's like every college campus
ever
but in the middle of all that you have
volstag who chimes in and is like yeah
you should have seen it
our king back from that fairytale land
that snake had trapped him in and just
kind of goes on about everything
happening with donald blake and all that
kind of stuff now for those of you guys
who didn't see that video thor takes
this personally and he gets mad and the
reason why is because it was just this
thing that nobody ever took into
consideration the fact that wolfstag
really kind of calls it like a fairy
tale land pisses thor off to the point
that he actually starts screaming at
volstag and is like like you guys have
no idea what you're talking about right
to feel so helpless right to have faces
of your fathers look down on you in
indignation to look into the sky and see
your home burning by your own shadow
right to have your lightning your own
odin damned hammer betray you none of
you guys know what this is like now the
last little tidbit there in terms of
thor referring to his hammer betraying
him that's the fact that the hammer just
won't let thor lift it but it'll let
other people lift it remember donnie
case is building off the work of jason
aaron and one of the things that jason
aaron had established is that the hammer
mjolnir is the way that it is because
odin had captured a cosmic storm at one
point in time and then trapped it inside
the hammer and the overall gist of what
jason aaron was doing was saying the
hammer is sentient the hammer while
there is a a kind of enchantment that
you know whosoever lifts this hammer if
you be worthy shall possess the power of
thor and so on and so forth that the
hammer chooses who gets to wield it but
that was a way for jason aaron to
explain the idea that some people could
lift the hammer and some people couldn't
in relation to the nature of the
enchantment itself and the hammer has
chosen not to allow thor to lift it at
least with any real measure of
consistency the other part of this is
that whenever it came to like donald
blake there was never really much in the
way of an explanation in terms of what
happened to him regarding thor right
that the fact that thor would turn into
donald blake and then donald blake would
turn to thor and so on and so forth but
the reality is that donald lake had just
kind of been trapped in like this sort
of false reality forever and it just
kind of gone insane but the truth about
it is that it was a very dark place and
it was a very terrible place thor going
through there and realizing everything
he knew and loved had basically been
destroyed the world serpent had been
killed right his entire life had
seemingly come crashing down because he
understood what it meant to actually be
donald blake that being this person that
swaps places with thor that it's
actually a sentence of torment that it's
not really a reprieve or anything along
those lines has really thrown him into
disarray and so where he storms off yet
again going and trying to lift his
hammer to fully understand what's going
on he's able to kind of pick it up to a
degree but the hammer is so ridiculously
heavy right so it really seems that the
hammer while it's not necessarily
working against thor per se it's not
making it easy for him and that's where
thor's like i don't understand what's
going on here because then the hammer
comes flying up and it just hits thor in
the chest knocks him to the ground
smashes the table and then loki comes
walking in and thor's kind of ashamed
here right he was like i can't stand the
hammers on my chest and lucky just picks
it up moves it out of the way so thor
can get up and then thor is able to
actually lift his hammer right so
there's a lot of inconsistency here now
it's not really an error of donny kate's
in terms of this inconsistency the
hammer is basically like comcast cable
it only ever works half the time and
when it does work it doesn't work right
so because of this thor is really
wrestling with this issue the things
just aren't working out the way they're
supposed to be now there is another
underlying theme going on here and we'll
talk about that here in a little bit but
instead he basically storms off right
and he tells loki i'm gonna go see sif
right because she's basically the new
heimdall the one that controls the
bifrost bridge and then i'm gonna go see
captain america and we're gonna get this
worked out right so when he shows up on
earth the offenders are doing what the
avengers do right which like fighting
some threat out there or something like
that i love the way that donnie kate's
handles this because it's like meanwhile
on earth it's like oh my god there's
like an alien invasion or something like
that and thor shows up and he was like
captain america i need to talk to you
and he's like yeah man i don't have
anything going on you know it's not a
great huge deal you know what like these
these robots are just like like these
robot monsters are attacking everything
and finally she hulk's like thor can you
help us out he's like oh yeah sure one
moment it's like
you should write lightning everywhere so
i loved that i absolutely adored that
whole thing but this is cool because
when captain america and thor kind of
start talking to each other that where
there is a little bit of banter going
back and forth between like thor and
iron man because remember they're still
in the midst of their prank war
remember it all started with thor
putting iron man's name like in
inscribing it on the hammer and then
throwing the hammer to earth and then
like iron man's private phone number was
publicly available to the world and so
after that they just kind of started
going back and forth but where thor
shocks iron man captain america's like
look dude you can't do that and then the
hammer goes after captain america like
literally tries to hit captain america's
shield right almost attacks him and so
it's kind of like okay like what in the
world is going on here and that's when
thor reveals to steve rogers he's losing
control of his hammer he's losing
control of the ability to control
mjolnir and captain america's response
is okay yeah that's kind of a big thing
let's go talk
let's go have a conversation now this is
one of the most interesting aspects of
the thor mythos right and it's one that
you always kind of knew but you never
really gave a whole lot of thought to
the nature of this conversation is that
thor asked captain america like when was
the last time we saw each other and
where captain america was like what are
you talking about he's like well i mean
just humor me he's like well i mean
there was the fight against noel and
then like the whole phoenix force thing
and all that kind of like i don't
understand why are you asking this and
thor says because he doesn't remember he
says he never really does and he's like
that's the price of immortality and it's
a cool thing because he's like for you
right now this life that you're living
or even somebody like like tony stark
let's say maybe 80 years that he gets on
this world it's his whole world he's
like but i've been alive for thousands
of years and i will live for thousands
more this moment you and i here right
now having this conversation blink of an
eye right in like 500 years i will
scarcely remember this moment and it's
this crazy thing where he's like that's
the price of immortality and you kind of
have to believe that's true it's not
that he doesn't care about captain
america but it's simply just that he's
been alive for so long and the brain can
only store so much in terms of memories
that it all just kind of fades away so
he and captain america facing off
against null as far as he's concerned
may as well have been something that
happened 20 years ago and it's kind of a
funny thing he's like that's why i'm
always so ecstatic when i come back to
earth and i see you guys because i don't
have a concept of time i don't
understand like i i get time right like
a minute leads to hours leads to days
leads to weeks and months and years and
decades and centuries and so on but for
me it all just kind of coalesces
together so every time i come back here
it's good to see that you're still alive
i could be an asgard for 500 years and
not know and then when i come back here
you're long since dead and it's some
other you know some five centuries later
version of captain america it's one of
the cool things because you always kind
of find yourself in these situations
where like there's some event taking
place out there and you find yourself
wondering like where's thor like why
isn't thor here and it's a great way for
donnie kate to kind of throw in this
idea because time for him doesn't work
the same way that it does for us
especially when he's in asgard where
there really is no concept of time i
mean i guess there is insofar as like
sunrise and sunsets and things like that
but like no one's pulling up uh you know
some device saying alexa what time is it
no one's saying that right which i hope
by the way your alexa devices didn't go
off
i apologize if they did but it's one of
those things right i mean it's just it's
it's so fascinating to see it focus in
that way and small little things like
that are what make donnie kate's work so
cool but at the end of the day he's like
i think i know why my hammer is not
working and the the response of captain
america is why and thor's like because
the hammer was given the inscription for
a warrior for for a person who fights
right for a soldier but i am not a
soldier i'm a king now i don't go out
into yotenheim and fr and fight frost
giants right i don't go into musfulheim
and fight certain i don't do things like
that anymore my job is to sit on the
throne of asgard and to govern asgard
now there is a bit of shame in this
conversation that he's having because if
you're a guy who defined your existence
by the enemies you are facing and your
ability to overcome them and then
suddenly you're thrust into the life of
just sitting on a throne and monitoring
a place and making sure that it does
what it's supposed to do you kind of
lose your sense of self and that's
probably what's really leading to thor
losing the ability to wield his hammer
and that's what he speculates i don't
know who i am anymore like i don't know
what my place is right like he's like
i'm supposed to be a warrior that's what
i'm supposed to be but maybe i'm
conflicted right maybe i know what i'm
supposed to be doing but i'm not doing
it which is where this kind of issue
comes from right what thor is
experiencing here is an existential
crisis and so as a result of this like
america's like like what are you saying
like like i don't i don't you know i
don't claim to understand any of this
but are you saying that somehow like for
like the the hammer's given up on you
now that you're a king because you're
not really a warrior anymore and the
response of thor is i don't think that's
the case i feel that's the case right
and i am no king he's like i am not an
honorable king not the kind of king that
i should be and he's like not yet and so
he basically says like i came here to
tell you that like i will live a
thousand years and a thousand more
lifetimes and so because of that like
asgard will outlive me and so he
basically gives the hammer of thor to
captain america and says like your job
is to keep it safe he's like the hammer
is no longer mine right like it's just
it's my job to do whatever i need to do
to kind of go on this bit of a journey
for himself now following that you
switch over to this nightmare that thor
continually has and donnie cates had
been teasing this for quite some time
remember that's one of the first things
we saw in donnie kate's run was the
nightmare of thor which was the return
of thanos not only just thanos thanos
wielding the arm or using the arm of
what looked like the destroyer as well
as having the hammer mjolnir with
infinity stones all over it leading an
army of the undead right i mean
literally it's the worst case scenario
for thanos right like like mjolnir with
infinity stones on it
it's kind of crazy and the during this
whole nightmare sequence the response to
thanos is like this is over asgardian
right you fought well you will dine and
you're a valhalla tonight i will make
sure of it all you must do is fall and
thor simply just won't die and so thanos
attacks him again which by the way for
those of you guys who never read like
thanos wins which is what donnie cates
wrote donnie cates is a master of
handling thanos it is stupid how good he
writes that character like thanos just
looks so menacing like he's just he's
just just this ridiculously menacing guy
but like at the end of the day like thor
is like please right please do not do
this there must be another way and
thanos gives the most thanos response
ever right he was like you you're the
mighty king of asgard right kings do not
beg and then he kills thor and then thor
wakes up and that's the crazy thing is
like this return of thanos it's coming
this is not like a kind of dream
sequence that may or may not come to
pass it looks like this is what donnie
case is building up to in his four run
which
by god i can't wait until wait until
that event unfold i feel like it's going
to be a marvel event i feel like we're
gonna be like king and black or
something like that which i think is
cool i'm really really excited about
that but essentially this whole dream
sequence as he's having it it's being
explained to jane foss to remember jane
foster's valkyrie now it's where marvel
just kind of shuffled her off to the
cornfields that after the jason aaron
run where she was thor and then she
essentially lost the mantle or the
mantle was given up or what have you
jane foster they had to find a place for
so they ended up making her valkyrie so
essentially she's part warrior queen
part you know shepherding the dead off
to the afterlife that kind of thing but
at the end of the day she kind of
explains it all to him and so you know
he was like well you know at the end of
the day you know i took the hammer and i
handed it over to the avengers and she's
like wait let me see if i understand
this you saw a vision of thanos the mad
titan a demigod who is all but immortal
and obsessed with death wielding mjolnir
with infinity stones attached to it and
your
thoughts was to just give it away to
give the hammer to the avengers where
literally anybody can just come in and
pick it up where thanos could just show
up on earth at any moment and just take
the hammer and no one's gonna be able to
stop him like that was your thought it
wasn't to like lock it in some vault in
asgard or some place where no one can
get to it and the response of thor is
like hey hot dog stand right and just
totally tries to dodge the question
which i absolutely love i absolutely
love that but it's one of those things
where like you you kind of have this
weird situation like the wrecking crew
show this is what's going on in jane
foster's stories right the wrecking crew
you understand why nobody's really
reading this right now right the
wrecking crew no one cares about the
wrecking crew the wrecking crew doesn't
even care about their wrecking crew they
don't take themselves seriously at all
it's like they fight him for a little
while the day saved yeah
you know jay foster's like i gotta go
find the rest of the wrecking crew and
thor's like okay cool whatever he leaves
that's literally what happens like they
just kind of fight for like a few
seconds i feel like it's just a way to
fill space in the comic and like that
was basically it maybe they'll become
important later on i highly doubt it but
in the midst of all this basically the
the crows were previously the crows of
odin which are now the pros of uh of
thor are set upon him and then it turns
out he's actually being being summoned
by freya right like by his mother which
of course you know you have to be a fool
to ignore mom and so thor is like okay
cool sif take me to where i need to be
now the crazy thing about this in the
last we'd heard of freya her and odin
had basically taken off into places
outside of the 10 realms in order to
basically work on their marriage what's
good for them right they decided to take
a vacation like outside of all reality
to go work on work on their vacation i
mean it sounds a little strange when you
say it hey me and the wife are going
through some struggles oh damn that's
crazy man i mean you guys working on it
yeah we're gonna leave all of reality to
fix it like really you're gonna leave
all all creation like all all things in
existence yeah man we found this portal
that leads into oblivion
i don't know how you have that
conversation with somebody but it's it's
a it's a cool thing right and so once
thor arrives here at essentially the
singing forest of anaheim that he's
actually met by odin now here's the
thing thor and odin man they've got a
rough history one of the things to know
is that once odin had essentially
vacated right once he and freya had left
and it was thor who who was really going
to be left in as the leader of asgard it
was kind of done unceremoniously i mean
there was a kind of like christening and
all that kind of stuff it was really
more of of odin just being like you're
in charge now son peace and then this
bailed that was basically it right not
only that when you talk about the
relationship between thor and odin it's
very very strained and it has been for a
long long time it was one of those
things where odin in a lot of ways kind
of looked down on thor right like in
some ways thor was honorable in other
ways odin was just continually
disappointed with him and so i would
definitely say there are some father
issues from thor towards odin but it's
one of those things where the
relationship has just always been kind
of a strained one and so what that leads
to is the two of them kind of
momentarily arguing for a few minutes
when thor believes that odin had
actually used the name of freyja to
summon him here and then of course
they're meant by like this giant beast
that just comes crashing into him only
for us to find out once that beast is
essentially destroyed that it really was
freya that seemed to have summoned him
here more so than that freya is not
alone she's here with angela now for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with angela and in reality it would
probably do us well to do a character
explanation on the character of angela
because she was originally a spawn
character who was rolled over into
marvel comics just by virtue of rights
ownerships and whatnot but the overall
origin of this is that while you did
have the 10 realms at one point heaven
was considered one of the realms of
asgard which was connected to asgard and
i guess maybe you could kind of consider
it to be like an asgardian territory or
something like that but a war eventually
broke out between heaven and asgard and
so angela at least in terms of her
origin as she'd been rolled into marvel
comics which was covered originally as
part of a tie-in issue to the original
sin event i want to say it was original
sin like 5.1 um that basically angela is
the biological daughter of freya and
odin which means technically she's the
rightful heir to the throne but she had
been taken essentially ran off to to the
to the realm of heaven so when it was
cut off she was cut off with it and so
that's why you had never seen her before
is because she was literally just
removed from all reality just kind of
floating out there in existence
somewhere with all the other angels in
heaven this kind of cast off 11th realm
and so because of that once angela
returned during original sin it was
amazing to see she beat the hell out of
thor and loki man it was amazing i
absolutely loved it i don't know if we
ever covered that story but where angela
showed up in original sin it was like
what
is this like a spawn crossover i didn't
know what to make of it when i first saw
it she's one of those characters when
she was thrown into marvel comics with a
quickness marvel was like this girl is
not to be trifled with like she is
hardcore it's cool and so that's kind of
where where she's the actual sister
she's really more of a half sister of
thor because thor is not the biological
child of of odin and freya that's one
thing to remember that odin's biological
mother is gaia right the sentience of
mother earth and then apparently also
the phoenix force i guess maybe not
really we're not really sure uh it's
just one of those things that may or may
not be the case it's kind of weird
because like that's what's happening in
avengers or at least that's what was
established in avengers by jason aaron
but it doesn't necessarily look like
that's what's going on here in the in
the story and we'll kind of cross that
bridge here in a second we'll talk about
that talk about why that's the case but
like there's this huge fight that
basically breaks out like when all the
younglings like the children of like
these these you know this giant monster
show up right the kids the little kids
are like bloodlusted so freya is like
i'll be right back and then she comes
back on a giant cat with like mini guns
on the side it looks amazing i would
absolutely love to see that in the mcu
just like a giant cat with mini guns it
just looks awesome right it just it just
looks ridiculously cool but of course
once everything kind of calms down then
you know a great big huge thing goes on
and so you know they kind of do a little
bit of a pow-wow and again like angela
does not really like odin at all right
so there's a bit of argument going on
there and this kind of rumor of like the
goddess of the hunt actually turns out
to be freya so that's a cool little plot
point the fact that her and odin just
couldn't reconcile their marriage so it
seems like they're basically divorced or
split up or kind of they're doing their
own thing they seem more separated than
anything under normal circumstances
separated basically means like you're on
your way to a divorce you just haven't
filled out the paperwork yet but it
seems like they're separated in so far
as they're like let's just take a break
away from each other and if we feel like
coming back cool if we don't well then
you know we'll sign the documents and
then i'll get half of everything you
know like half of asgard you know some
along those lines but again a kind of
argument breaks out between the two but
because things don't really seem to be
going in a peaceful direction the
response of of freya is i need to talk
to thor angela take odin and get him out
of here right like go go do something
and so essentially odin looks it looks
like he ends up in like this giant giant
facility like this this giant place
looks like a giant battle arena which
looks kind of cool where he's just
fighting enemy after enemy which i
absolutely want to read that is like a
one-off comic like odin just fighting
like this endless wave of monsters it
just looks cool but there's this
conversation that happens between freya
and thor now this is where i say it
seems like there's a bit of
inconsistency here because of course
freya draws on the idea that like yes
odin's always had a very you know
tenuous and strained relationship with
all of his children right you're not the
only one that he had a a strained
relationship with loki's the same way
angela's the same way sure they don't
hate their dad but they don't love him
in the same way that you would like
normally love a father right i mean he
says like his children there is so much
that you still do not know secrets that
i dare not speak with regards to freyja
talking about the kinds of things that
odin has been engaged in over the course
of his life and it's one of the funny
things is because freya says like i
changed your diapers i taught you to
read i held you when you wept and when
you laughed and fed you from my own body
she says like mother is like the first
word that you ever spoke and you spoke
it to me i may not have carried you i am
not gaia i am not the phoenix but none
of that matters i am your mother end of
story now this is where things get a
little bit murky because if it had just
been a reference to phoenix it would
have all made sense and for those of you
guys who aren't familiar with that in
thor volume 1 issue number 301 we
learned that gaia was the actual
biological mother of thor but in thor
volume 8 issue number 42 the one that
jason aaron is writing that it actually
turned out it was the phoenix that
procreated with odin and gave birth to
thor and so the fact that donnie cades
seemingly references both and freya
saying i'm not gaia and i'm not the
phoenix still kind of leads us to wonder
who's the actual biological mother of
thor right is it just the more recent
change worse just the phoenix and it's
always just kind of in the phoenix or is
it the old thor 301 story where it was
gaia it's one of those weird little
things that we have a hard time
referencing or consolidating because
marvel seems to or really seems to be a
little washy about it and so freya
actually makes reference to thor's reign
as king and thor's like i've heard what
people are saying right the black reign
of the thunder god i've heard it all and
so when she asks like why are you so
cruel to everybody there right you don't
have to be like odin you don't have to
be just this this hard guy who's
seemingly cruel to everybody around him
you don't have to be that way right you
can forge your own path you can be an
enlightened king a kind king and a great
king the response of thor is it's not
that he's like the the bigger issue the
biggest thing that's really bothering
for here is he has no heir and he
probably never will he's like i've i
have no air whatsoever i have no son to
call my own i don't get don't get it
wrong thor has definitely knocked boots
in the past but he doesn't have a kid
right there's no one to take over the
throne of asgard following his death and
so his stance here is i will be the last
and final king of asgard and so it's one
of those things where his mom's like
really that's what bothers you i mean
take an air take as many airs as you
want it doesn't really matter and the
response of thor is not necessarily well
it's because i haven't found a woman
that i love he's found a lot of women
that he loved over the course of his
life his response here is i will not
raise a child to inherit this cursed
throne not after what i have seen not
after thanos and so what really seems to
be hitting at him here is this fear that
thanos will arrive here and thanos will
destroy him and that because there will
be no rightful heir that there will be
no one to rule asgard after his stead
but even if he could have a rightful
heir does he really want to doom a child
to death at the hands of thanos because
one thing to keep in mind thanos takes
no prisoners right no quarters given
when thanos comes for you like that's
you're dead that's basically it doesn't
matter how old you are doesn't matter
none of that stuff right beg for your
life whatever it is if thanos wants to
kill you you will die right he's just
remorseless in that way and so in a lot
of ways thor's kind of backed against
the wall here and so that's one of the
crazy things because the response of
freyja is thor like don't you can't look
at it that way right how many times has
the world been on the brink of
destruction and how many times have we
put it back together when it was
destroyed how many times have you and
the avengers faced off against some
universe ending threat and how many
times have you come out on top i
understand the fear of the mad titan
right this guy obsessed with death
showing up on earth with a hammer in his
hand covered in infinity stones i
totally understand the worry behind that
but you've defeated worse and they have
right like he's you know she's like
you've survived worse and they really
really have right thor's proven himself
multiple times and so she's like we'll
face this together you know everything
will be fine no matter what it happens
to be and that's that's when thor's cell
phone goes off it doesn't look like an
iphone but i would like to believe that
it is surely thor's not some kind of
heathen that he carries an android
device i'm sorry android users iphones
are superior i feel like i'm gonna get
so much hate for this comment
i feel like i'm gonna get so much hate
people are just gonna be lighting me up
on those keyboards man but nonetheless
it's captain america calling and what we
thought would happen is exactly what did
happen right that mjolnir is gone that
somebody broke into the avengers
facility and somebody stole the hammer
of thor with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace